top fives magnus carlsen versus hikaru
nakamura yes a top five we're about to
get right into it let's go here's the
first one this one is magnus carlsen
versus ikaro nakamura in 2011
at the tata steel so uh nakamura's
playing black here is black to move and
nakamura took this pawn here so he's
capturing the pawn maybe he has some
type of play down the c file here maybe
be able to move the knight in and if
we're able to maybe try to make white's
king here which is kinda safe on the
other side magnus actually has some type
of attack here but you gotta find the
right move and here is a nice one white
to move what do you do in this position
here's what magnus said magnus says you
know what it's time it's time so he
hitting bishop takes h6 and we in the
mix oh my goodness that's a big boy move
from a big fella open up the file with a
smile so after bishop takes eight six
stairs g takes h6 right back because
he's like i gotta kind of do that and
then after g takes uh h6 there's g7 what
a move it's going down oh my goodness
right g7 attacks the bishop right so if
you take it which he
carl did not do there's knight at five
and we live gg start a new game this
one's completely over right if you try
rook c7 knight takes h6 using the pin oh
my goodness everything's gonna fall
you're getting made it very soon right
so in fact he didn't want to go for that
nakamura said okay clever i'm going to
move out the way bishop v7 so we're
pretty good here next move is on you why
to move now what do you do can you
finish
here it is right after bishop e7 rook
takes h6
oh my goodness it's mates here this
rook's looking good black still has no
attacking no attack so after rook takes
h6 there's knight to f7 doing well
defending like a beast right rook h8
actually becomes a blunder knight takes
pawn takes if this is what you were
thinking oh got rook h1 well as you
thought you did this is a family channel
we're not gonna put that on the screen
okay so that's not gonna work for you so
after uh rook takes h6 knight to f7
knight to f7 attacks the rook and now
you need something to do rick h8 doesn't
work what do you do
this is what magnus did he found the
best move obviously queen g6 you also
had queen h2 but queen g6 is a really
strong move threatening checkmate not
this way because the queen's defending
but queen h7 is checkmate on the move
after queen g6 nakamura is like cool get
rid of another piece we got to get rid
of these pieces around my king queen
takes h6 threatening queen h8 mate
because the file once again oh my
goodness so what does he do he blocks it
bishop f6 because if you take with the
rook you're mated and if you take with
the queen
i think he's still winning actually he
actually is he's still winning if you
take with the queen right but queen h8
is the move here queen hhh after king f7
all right guys come on come on what's
the move what are you gonna do this
one's fun this one's fun
if you said
rook takes f6
you're wrong that is not it rick takes
f6 i got king e7 and i'm actually
drawing this game somehow it's a crazy
game right really doesn't work the way
that you thought it would so in fact the
move here is g8 queen ouch
wow two queens in fact three on the
board three queens on the board and
after a rook takes g8 because that's
like force queen takes f6 king e8 and
the finale you can find this one pretty
easily white to move pause the video if
you need to here it is rookie won and
he's done he actually resigned right
here rookie one check right so after
king f7 you work e7 i mean in king d8
but the easy way is just mate with e7
ricky seven steel works but just
checkmate they don't play around anymore
queen e7 is made so the resignation
happened right here after rook e1 that
was number one now let's look at number
two okay guys here's number two so we
have magnus carlsen versus hikaru
nakamura in 2011 at the bosnia kings
tournament so here we go um now if you
look at the let's take stock of the
position see what's going on there this
is swashbuckling there's a lot going on
for white it looks like we're almost
mating you're gonna have to take with
the queen and then for black maybe
knight c3 might almost work this the
works on the seventh rank or second rank
like kind of the same right there's
there's a lot of stuff going on in this
position but i think white is the one a
little bit closer because knight c3 just
doesn't work just yet so with that being
said here
nakamura's like you know what i need to
get rid of this queen and you have a lot
of pressure on my position so he plays
queen e5 i said look we got to trade
these off now that's always a good thing
if you're being attacked trade the
pieces that are attacking you right so
after queen e5 we capture rook takes e5
g takes f5 and g takes f5 why did he
capture so that we can open the file
with a smile right rooks love the open
files so you want to have an open one to
use now in this position you could play
rook after g1 but there's a better move
or in fact a more uh let's say forcing
move here why to move what would you do
here it is guys in fact instead of
moving one of the rooks to g1 it was
knight to f3 attack the rook why not
very nice move makes the rook move and
once the rook moves then we go rook f to
g one check could have checked with the
other rook two as well this bishop's
here but we may want to use this to push
eventually so after rick after g1 there
was k287 and now right here you look at
the board
and you're like what what do i actually
do here what do i he has it covered
he has it covered and he also could take
it
so does the check really work night h4
me kind of
but he has a past pawn like how do you
do this why to move what would you do in
this position
magnus says yeah the square is covered
but we're going to put the rook there
anyway
rick g7 check we don't care about the
square being covered says magnus after
rook takes g7 we're gonna take these oh
my goodness and after king takes which
is forced bishop um to h6 and that is a
wrap so you're gonna move your king i'm
gonna take the rook and uh you know
watch where you look there so it's a
rapture so that's gonna be over so he
said oh that's cool that's okay at least
my rook is defended so i can move my
king to aj he moves out of the way well
okay double on the file with a smile
they love those files right put the rook
here and didn't have to work to at work
after e8 just to defend this rook maybe
some rook e1 in the future or rook to e2
but right now we're just defending
black's just defending so how do you
increase the pressure right you know can
we can we increase the pressure in this
position it is right to move what do you
do now
here it is guys you need more pieces
right it takes multiple pieces for a
successful attack i mean you have these
but we're not successful yet the bishop
is on the wrong color really we would
love to have a light square bishop but
we don't but we do have a knight
and then i can bounce around over here
to h4 for the score knight g6 is made in
wii grades wow
can you even stop it without even giving
up material right rook g6 just runs
right into the same thing knight to g6
doesn't matter and we get the exchange
there so picaro says oh no not today
rick takes g7
and that's the end of the game in fact
resignation on the spot after rick takes
g7 as pawn takes g7 right h takes g7 and
then king h7 and knight f5 knight at
five we're going to play rook h1 and
rook h8 and this game is completely over
and also if you go uh king to g8 even
worse knight takes a f5 with knight
eight six inch intentions rook h1 and
rook to h8
will be very devastating so the last
move here was after rick takes g7 the
game was over here but pawn takes g7
will be next you could also take with
the rook as well i mean even here knight
g6 with winning some material ricky six
and knight to g6 or even knight takes f5
still wins weirdly enough but knight g6
takes takes and this one's just
completely over however you want to do
it here white was winning very good one
now let's go to number three okay guys
here we are with number three this one
is ikaro nakamura versus magnus carlsen
in 2018 at thechest.com speed chats
championship now he car was playing
white here and actually e5 was played by
magnus so after e5 right uh icarus says
i'm just gonna take it let's just see
what he does open up the center a little
bit knight takes e5 knight takes c5 from
ikaru and rook takes c5 keeping the
material balance even here says magnus
and just keeping the balance here and
now white here plays a simple move can
you find it what would you play in this
position should be very obvious to a lot
of you guys but if not you're going to
learn here it's right to move what do
you do here it is guys you got to get
your king out of the center as you're
opening up the center you probably don't
want to have your king still there so he
just gets out the way in castles and
then magnus plays okay cool you castle
he takes c4 this was the plan anyway
right get a little pin going with 94
maybe right you can't take with the
bishop because your queen's pin and if
you take with the pawn damage structure
you know 94 is coming in there maybe we
can bully this pawn pretty nice position
says magnus so what do you think icaru
did about this it's right to move what
do you do
in fact hicaro here picked up his bishop
and said boom
magnus you hang queens too don't you big
fella the magnus carlsen the world
champion hung his queen in this position
so hopefully you feel better back at
home if you're hungry queen today it's
okay we love you you're gonna be just
fine bishop takes age seven wow look at
that magnus carlsen did hang this and
after king takes queen takes d8 and the
game's over he drops a queen ouch
ouch magnus crossing goes down in this
game this is 2018 simple blunder but it
happened hey carl took advantage of it
he got him 2018 here chess.com
speedchest championship that was number
three now let's move to number four okay
guys here we are with number four this
one is magnus carlsen versus hikaru
nakamura in 2020 at the magnus chess
tour finals right so hikaru is playing
black first off you're looking at this
position like what is going on what
actually happened in this game right
because the king is on d7 it looks like
black bots are getting mated what is
this what is it one two three four five
pieces for black white has one two three
four so white sacrificed a piece but it
looks scary for black's king bishop g4
from magnus here pin to win with queen
takes d5 as being a move because he got
the double pin going i mean look at how
nasty that is right so he finds uh one
of the best moves here in fact like the
only moving away you know he can play
king e8 but king to c6 was the move here
king c your king is on c6 this is an
amazing game
also this is defended so just in case
you wanted to capture he doesn't but
then we have this move right here boom
what bishop takes e6 looks ridiculous
he's already down a piece now we sacking
another one you are absolutely scared
for your life here bishop takes e6 and
rook to f6 now if this doesn't work
black's just up two pieces right now so
we got the pin to win king d7 back that
boy right back up defending everything
no good checks uh oh so looks kind of
scary queen to b6 okay hitting the e6
bishop how do you defend it right
how do you even defend this well you
don't you just move it bishop to d5 now
there's like 20 moves left here so we're
going to go through this but after
bishop to d5 there was rick d6 check he
goes back to ea because he's like yo it
feels like i'm getting mated everywhere
but at least i got this little like you
know diamond or or across here to just
like i can go around these squares and
be just fine king e8 rick takes d5 and
says all right cool you know what magnus
like all right cool i got to get some of
this material back i have a queen in a
rook i can't do this by myself so knight
takes d5 queen c6 check hitting the
knight and the rook at the same time
king e7 queen b7 if you go back i'm
taking the so he walks up the king is on
e6
it was on c6 it was on d7 it's
ridiculous here queen c6 check again
king e7 you want to draw what do you
think are you gonna take a draw here
what do you think
nope we don't draw nothing we don't draw
anything king f5 and we live the king is
on f5
unbelievable the king's on f5 queen
takes d5 feels like you still getting
mated somehow somewhere with your king
out here in the middle of the street in
wilderness by himself king five queen e7
boom defending everything
e6 check mother king back you can't do
it with just your queen it works too far
away and oh where did your pieces go
right this is not looking that good
anymore is it king g6 queen e4 check
king g7 we take on d4 king g8 checkaboo
checky poo like just check check check
check queen g7 queen c4
b2
right and then after f4 this is still
looking scary
rook to be a queen e4 and after queen e4
guys what would you play in this
position let's just see if you're if
you're ready for this right black to
move what do you do now if you can feel
the pressure f5 maybe some queen d5 in
there what's going to happen what do you
do and this is this is like move number
one on the engine too like so strong
chest here it was rook h7
by ikaru rick h7 number one on the
engine too just so you know rick h7
stopping like e7 pushing and stuff work
to be one defending the pawn and at this
point i mean this is over right your
attack is gone my king went on a you
know field trip right it starts on e8
obviously field trip up here we're gonna
walk around we're gonna come back this
way you know we gonna see oh this is
cool oh man this is just you know like
the king went everywhere right look at
this route the king took in this game
after rick b1 queen b7 queen e2
and then rook to c7 and then
magnus resigned like there's no more
moves this is insane to have your king
where it was
where it was here wow like this was
amazing this was amazing sequence of
moves guys from um from carl here
stepping out of danger bringing the king
back around oh you got one check cool
you got no more oh maybe a few maybe a
few right check check check check check
didn't we going forward he says you
ain't got nothing you don't have enough
pieces we actually defend this square as
well so we had to take the knight queen
comes back to defend everything and then
we just go to work e6 bring the king
back home to civilization and
everything's fine and everything's fine
he was able to pull this game out what a
phenomenal game back in 2020 against
magnus crossing here that's number four
and now here is the final one number
five okay and here we are with number
five this one is hikaru nakamura versus
magnus carlsen in 2021 at the ftx crypto
cup all right so the last move was eight
takes b5 from magnus here this actually
you know first off let's think about
let's let's ask a question here what
opening do you think this one came from
what opening do you think this position
actually came from think about it what's
your answer
not a roy lopez berlin this was from a
berlin the ones that put you to sleep
right you know you say berlin and sleep
going the same sentence here and this
was a berlin roy lopez opening like a
variation of the roy lopez but this is
like wow berlin he takes b5 and after a
takes b5 rook to a one for mikaro he's
like yo i gotta get something going here
i gotta get some pressure here because
black is like what is this this almost
feels like some type of king's indian
but in fact there's no bishop on g7 so
now after rook a1 there was f4 for
magnus here say it's trying to open up
hey who's home open up the doors and
after f4 nice move here rook a6 counter
play attacking brook takes e6 and bishop
takes d5 obliterate in the center
pinning this right so you really got to
pay attention to this what a move here
saying i will take this i will take this
so magnet says okay i know you will and
moves the rook over here to the a to
defend d5 so now this doesn't have any
much merit to it anymore after the f3
move well this one's kind of a simple
one what would you do in this position
in fact right here you could actually do
a number of things you could actually
sack right now if you like but e3 just
more principle you know gain some more
space the queen actually is now tied
down to this rook here because the f3
pawn again never push f6 or f3 right
it's like fine gold says here and after
f3 you're already in some trouble
because now you have to stay around this
cool he understands that he puts his
clean on d1 nakamura does after queen to
d1 it's on you what do you do in this
position black to move queen f2 check
that's probably what you're thinking
some queen f2 maybe
you know clean f2 check seems pretty
good kind of like giving you the answer
here right queen f2 psych bishop takes
h3 that's for me
ouch well let's see what happens if he
captures if he captures then the move is
actually queen f2 not capturing one h3
giving him a chance to maybe consolidate
or move some pieces around even then
it's still very difficult even like rick
g6 is coming in here but queen f2 is a
nasty move king h1 then you take one f3
thank you that's check
king here and you have queen f2 it
doesn't matter where you put the king is
the same way
in fact uh this one actually mates this
one made it in six which is a crazy mate
but after king g wonders queen f2 check
right and then king king h1 you have f3
and this is ridiculous i mean there's
made everywhere everything's hanging i
mean oh my goodness i could probably
throw this in just just to do it just to
do it everything's made here right
really rough really rough so of course
after bishop takes h3 uh nakamura was
like you're not about to do this to me
on national television so he played rook
to g6
to defend and also maybe attack but not
realistic but maybe attack maybe sack
the rook on g4 just try to survive try
to survive well can he survive in fact
it is black to move in this position
what do you do
here it is guys here it is after rook to
g6
all right magnus plays bishop to f5 and
he hits the rook here so he's i'm gonna
hit the rook maybe bring the knight in
trying to check him here a lot of things
i can do here but bishop to f5 cool move
and you know instead of retreating the
rook somewhere
anywhere right what he did was a very
clever move here which is bishop to c2
pretty clever pretty clever you probably
still could take on g6 it makes it still
complicated right so do you take on g6
do you move the knight in like what do
you do here it's magnus's move
your move here chat what do you do
you watching at home what are you gonna
do here it's all up to you here here it
is hope you're ready for it bishop takes
c2 not g6 because now we can actually i
mean look at this this is one of the
coolest forks you will ever see i'm
taking a piece that can be captured but
i am forking at the same time right so
you know this is nice i captured a piece
and forking basically two two pieces for
free because after you take with the
queen i can just take on e1 and he's
done in fact ouch right now the queen
was the only thing defending e1 also
when you move the queen then i just come
back and you know for four seconds here
and everything must go sale so bishop
takes g6 everything's done right ouch
sheesh
and that's a wrap there and that was
number five this was the top five
carlson versus nakamura hope you guys
enjoyed it today now if you love these
make sure you check this next video
right above me don't go anywhere
subscribe to the channel as well we'll
see you guys on the next one
[Music]
you